hey what's happening my name is samuel
leeds and in this video i want to talk
about hmos
and particularly self-managing hmos if
you are managing your hmos
massive advantage to hmos you probably
know the advantages
more cash flow also if you've got a void
period you're still getting rent from
the other tenants
and i think the biggest advantage is
more cash flow okay um lots of other
things as well
like uh article four you buy you buy you
buy property you turn it into a hmo
um and then article four comes in you
then got automatic planning permission
it pushes the value of the houses up um
so hmos is something that i've been
doing for 12 years now
and i did manage my hmo as myself for a
very long time
and someone just messaged me in fact one
of my students
saying um they wanted some help they're
looking to manage some problems some
hmos themselves there's some questions
and i thought well geez rather than me
just shooting a video for ella
ella atrial who's an amazing property
investor who's on our property investors
academy
rather than me just shooting a private
video for her and sending it to ella
it might be appropriate for you as well
so i just shoot it and i'd stick the
whole video on youtube
so this is for ella but also for anybody
else who's interested in self-managing
hma properties so
ella says how did you reference
check against prospective tenants so
reference checking is really important
so for me when i was doing hmos
it was professionals i wanted
professionals only never mix your
tenants
don't have some students some
professionals some housing benefit
tenants
you want to know your market and you
want to literally just cater to them
only so
mine was professionals i did reference
check them reasonably heavily so i
wanted to see
um i wanted to see their they were
working
so i literally wanted a reference off
their employer to say yes
they are with us and um
also how much they're on i wanna know
that that they can afford the rent
they've got a decent job um if they're
on some job which is like commission
only
or not there's anything wrong with
commission only but for my tenants i
just want to see a little bit of
security
i want to see the they're in a secure
job they're on a decent
salary and by decent i mean um
depends on the rent if the rent is 500
pounds a month
for their rent and their salary is a
thousand pounds a month i might be
thinking ooh it's a bit low
but if they're on 2 000 pounds a month
obviously i can easily afford 500 pounds
a month
because it's all inclusive of bills so
that's the first thing their employer
second thing is
i want a reference check a credit check
now you can credit check people for very
very cheap and
it just shows you their that their
credit history now sometimes they might
not have the best credit in the world
and that might be something as little as
they paid a mobile phone bill
late one time but if they've got any
serious problems with their credit if
they've been bankrupted they've got
um you know judgments and all sorts
against them then that's a bad sign
so that's a check i'll do um i want to
see a reasonably good
credit so their job they want a decent
salary their credit is reasonably good
i also want to see a um a previous
landlord
check and i want to see you know where
are they currently living
but more importantly than where they're
currently living where were they living
before that
and what does their landlord have to say
about them so i'm going to say them look
i want to see
where you were previously living and i
want to see a chat i want to see a check
a reference from your previous
landlord the reason i'll often get a
previous landlord
is because their current landlord might
just want them out
because they're a bad tenant but their
previous landlord has got no axe to
grind
so that's the checks reasonably strict
now if they are
young and they're just leaving home or
something and
you know obviously they need a job but
if they can't get a previous landlord
check
if their credit if they're like 19 years
old and their credit is just a bit
you know it's not really showing all
that much or it's a bit bad
and they go oh my god it's bad because i
had this silly problem with this mobile
phone bill but you know what
it was a mistake and i'm a little bit
unsure then i'm going to ask for a
guarantor
and a guarantor is usually a parent or a
guardian
who's going to say look if they don't
pay the rent i'll pay the rent but then
you need to reference check the
guarantor you need to credit check the
guarantor
to check they're okay um so that's the
check so there's a lot of checks doesn't
cost much money at
all to do these checks uh most of the
checks are free
some of them like the credit check might
cost i think it was like 25 pounds
back in the day when i was doing it and
you can just google how to credit check
somebody
you can go on open rent open rent have a
thing that does this so that's the
checks
checks are straight be quite strict on
the checks because if you have a bad
tenant
that's that it can really really cause
problems and people that don't pay
they're moving they're not paying
they're often the kind of people also
just upset the other tenants and you can
end up with good tenants leaving because
of the bad tenant the bad tenants not
paying it's just a disaster so strictly
check your tenants in hmos next question
by the way if you find this helpful
i hope you'll find this helpful ella but
if you're watching this and you're
finding it helpful
and you're not on my academy do me a big
favor and just smash the like button
okay
free advice free advice for your own
property but smash the like button
right next question is what tenancy
deposit scheme
did you use so i actually didn't take
deposits when i was managing my hmos
and the reason i didn't take deposits
was because
it's a pain you've got to register them
you've got to pay to register them it's
about 35 pounds to register a deposit
and it was a selling point i used to use
when i used to move people in so i said
look it's hmo
it's all good it's all up and running
it's got the bills all included
and there's no deposit so that was like
a selling point it meant less admin for
me less hassle for me
that was just something i chose to do if
you want to charge deposits
charge deposits and you can register
them at mydeposits.com at uk
but that was just a choice i chose not
to do my attitude was
the reason you charge your deposit is
because if a tenant's bad trashes the
place
leaves without paying rent you take it
from the deposit but if you reference
check the tenant well in the first place
it's very unlikely they're going to do
that so strictly reference them don't
take deposits is what i chose to do
okay next did you provide all bedding
and soft furnishings within the price of
their room or just let them bring their
own bedding
okay so what i actually used to do was
i would provide bedding this is a little
naughty trick right now it's not naughty
if you're up front i would provide
bedding for the viewing and for the
photos and for the adverts because if
there's no bedding and
no soft furnishings it just looks
terrible
the room doesn't look good so i would
provide bedding
however i'd show them round
and they'd be like oh this is nice i'd
like it and all that and then i'd say
yes it is
and then i'd say to them oh by the way
if i sense they were wanting to go for
it
i'd say oh by the way um
the the bedding is actually not included
you can buy the bedding
and i'd sell them really cheap pretty
much at cost and the reason i would sell
the bedding
is because uh or say look you can bring
your own bedding or remove it it's just
here really for the photos and stuff
the reason i do that is because um it's
a hassle
providing bedding and stuff i used to
find a little bit of hassle and then if
it's like oh the mattress is lost
although this is broken or you know not
the mattress but the sheets are
you know gone bad it's my responsibility
to fix it because i provided it
so i always provide it for the viewings
always provided
for the viewings but don't necessarily
provide it for the actual
tenant themselves i hope that makes
sense what length of tenancy did you use
as standard
six months length and then rolling or
six months at a time
or longer much appreciated great
question so in terms of length of
tenancy
um yeah i mean you can do no length you
can do six months you can do 12 months
you can do two years
you can make them every time the
contract ends if it's a 12-month
contract you can say now you need to
sign up for another 12 months
i found that not great because if you
say to people now that six months or 12
months has ended
you need to commit to another six or 12
months often people would
not want to commit to that because they
don't know what's going to happen
and they're living in a room at the end
of the day no one necessarily lives in a
room
and they plan on staying there for three
four years that's usually a short-term
plan
usually the average tenant stays between
about
six months and 18 months so i used to
um i actually changed to begin with i
actually used to say
no length no minimum stay literally a
monthly rolling contract but i wouldn't
move someone in
unless i um unless they planned on
staying for six months
because that's what i used to do i then
did change it to a minimum of six months
but then it was always monthly rolling
um but the reason i did that and the
reason i think that works so well with
hmo tenants
is because a lot of people will say you
need to stay for a minimum of six months
and then it's six-month contract every
time
or 12 months or whatever and the problem
with that
is that it puts people off some of my
longest
tenants that stayed in my hmos for like
six years moved in
and only planned on living there for six
months so
they wouldn't have wanted to renew for
another six months if i said to them
you've got to stay here for a year they
would have said i don't want it i don't
want to commit to that i'll find
somewhere else
so get them in move them in
make sure they're not planning on
staying for two or three months because
it's not worth the hassle it's not worth
just letting even bothering to let them
in and move
it's not worth it change the sheets not
worth it so
i would say ask for a minimum of six
months
but in reality you know just make it
really flexible and then look after them
provide them with a good service and
hope that they end up staying
many years many do so anyway
there's a little nitty gritty golden
nuggets around hmo tenants
i hope you found this helpful ella
thanks for your questions i hope you
found this video helpful as well
and uh if you're watching this and
you're not hella again drop a comment
you've got more questions drop a comment
subscribe because i'm doing a lot more
videos like this so subscribe and i will
see you
next time thanks for watching